um good afternoon or good morning i
guess depending on where you are
um i am jackaman i'm an assistant
professor at ut southwestern
and it's my pleasure to introduce you
now our next speaker for this conference
susan rafaelski so she's the director of
essay development
at the allen institute for cell science
and i will leave it to her
to tell you about all the cool stuff
they are doing but just to introduce her
a little bit
um before the allen she was an assistant
professor at uc irvine
and in terms of her background her
bachelor's is in biochemistry molecular
and cell biology and math
all of them from the university of
arizona then she did a phd in
biochemistry from stanford university
followed by a postdoc
at the friday harbor labs and ucsf
and as you will see from her talk and if
you you know um look at her papers
all throughout her career her theme has
been lifestyle imaging
computational analysis image analysis
data analysis
to get a quantitative understanding of
the cell biological processes she is
studying so um with that i will
take it to her
hi i'm susan rafalski from the allen
institute of cell science and i'm
excited to tell you about
our work uh trying to understand sources
of variation in intracellular
organization
in stem cells at the allen institute
we believe that we should be able to
look at a cell and know what it is doing
what it did and what it will do and we
believe that because there's such a
strong relationship between cell
organization and function
and if we know where all the parts
important parts to do important things
in the cell are at a moment in time then
we should be able to know what the cell
will do
at the questions that we're interested
in at the institute are basic science
questions
how to define and categorize cells and
create a cell atlas
my favorite which is what are the
principles of cell organization
and then of course how change cells
change that organization as they move
between states
the system that we work in is uh stem
cells and so we have
a sort of differentiation and
regeneration bent to what we're doing
and of course we're very interested in
how that applies to disease especially
in stem cells which is such an important
model system for human disease
the approach at the institute is a
holistic one we care about the entire
cell
all parts of the cell coming together
and our mo is really 3d life cell
imaging because we care deeply about
dynamics in our new cells doing the
normal thing
our model system is the human induced
pluripotent stem cell
and its differentiation from this
undifferentiated pluripotent state
to the differentiated cardiomyocyte
we want to look at the most normal cells
possible and we want to look at
structures in those cells
so we chose to do endogenous tagging
with gfp
using crispr cas9 gene editing and then
generate clonal cell lines with a huge
amount of quality control which we also
release
to uh to the community we also develop
similarly well-established
and robust differentiation protocols
again the microscope is at our center
and we do 3d life cell imaging
um of snapshots or time lapse and we add
in
ways of referencing our cells using dyes
or other methods
to be able to pull out individual cells
out of a field of cells
we care about again the whole cell so we
have methods to work on integrating uh
information from cell lines that only
express one tag per cell line
to get a structural organization in a
holistic way and we're starting to
integrate other types of information
such as gene expression
in a spatial manner to integrate that
with structural organization
everything we do at the institute is
quantitative and has the purpose of
being used for analysis and modeling
and also all of this together for uh
distribution to our community for
empowerment of all
of us together the uh the model system
that we use
is of course the undifferentiated cell
uh to the cardiomyocyte because it's a
very well established differentiation
process and because of course by the
time you have the contractile apparatus
you've reorganized the cytoplasm
tremendously but we also have all of the
beautiful cell states in between
to start building a cell's state space
of cell organization
in this particular process today i'm
going to focus entirely on the
undifferentiated stem cell
but before i start that story i just
want to make one really important point
which is that if as one thing i do today
if i get you guys to go to alancell.org
and look at our website the allen cell
explorer so that you can see what we're
up to and what we have
available to you up there then i've
succeeded and it's definitely worth a
look
so we can take our cell lines one
structure at a time
and we can image them and characterize
these cells and then we can
uh also add positional referencing
markers so that we can image these on a
scalable integration assay
um for pipeline imaging to build these
uh integrated cells
and to analyze the variation what we
want to do is take these cells and move
them through state space
so understand how they change through
the cell cycle through stiffened states
like differentiation
and in response to perturbations like
specific agonists or mutations
so today i'm speaking in this wonderful
session called maximizing the value of
your image data
and i'm going to tell you one story that
relates to two different types
of data uh one which is um
uh one single movie of ourselves and the
other which is a very large collection
of 200 000
3d images of our cells
so we start with cell culture we do
image acquisition
but we've worked on a lot of methodology
to create
those data sets using as much
standardization and reproducibility as
possible so we
use a robotic platform for automated
cell culture maintenance and sample
preparation
when we're imaging we use automated
methods in order to identify the
location within our field of colonies
that we want to image a particular field
of view
and our workhorses are generally
spinning disc confocals we also have
some
semi super resolutionary scan and we
image thousands of replicates
of live cells in high resolution and
infidelity we have to handle the storage
image processing tracking but we try to
do all of that as much as possible with
open source software and tools and
approaches that we can then also share
with the community
so here's what our cells look like if we
move in 3d from the bottom to the top
we can see that the cells outline in
purple and in this particular case we're
also labeling mitochondria
and if we look at a visualization on the
side what that looks like in 3d you can
see our cells grow in very tightly
packed colonies and the third dimension
matters a lot these cells are ethical
basal epithelial like they have a top
and a bottom
and they contain very large nuclei
if we take the channels apart this is
what they look like and of course we can
start and say okay we've got our cells
we've got our structure and our dna
let's just segment the cells in nuclei
pull out the cells and let's move on
the problem is of course this is all in
flea dimensions and very tightly packed
cells so this is quite hard
and the other challenge is that we're
not doing this for one structure but in
this case for 25 different structures
and finding ways to do that successfully
even in a first pass way is quite
challenging so we
created a software toolkit that we use
in-house that helped us a lot with this
the allen cell structure segmenter
it combines some classic best
segmentation algorithms
to do the structure segmentation
together with uh
deep learning uh segmentation via
iterative deep learning specifically to
get to our cells and nuclei and i'll
show you what that looks like
so this is the framework for the allen
cell structure segmenter it has
one classic image segmentation workflow
that's what we use for the structures
and um if you look at these particular
images and the z
stacks um as we move through ourselves
and you find this interesting
to your own work please come and check
out our tool
uh we've tried to build it in a way that
it's modular for many different uses of
many structures within the cell and just
come and check out the website out
the second part of our workflow is to
use integrative deep learning where we
use the output which hopefully has been
you know
optimized in a way that you like of the
traditional segmentation
in order to create um training uh
training sets
to then do deep learning segmentation on
and there's just one curation step
needed here
it's very difficult to do a lot of
manual curation in 3d so instead of
doing it in 3d we do it by creating
these segmentations
and doing either sorting or merging to
create those ground truths and then
build our models
and that's what we used for ourselves in
nuclei
there are video tutorials available for
both of those workflows and we have a
forum online so please come check this
out and see if it's useful for you
here is an example of what our cell and
nuclear segmentation looks like so this
is the dna
and this is the membrane this is what
the model output looks like and that's
in a whole field of view so to get to
individual cells we combine
um the dna in order to seed watershed of
cell identification in the cells in
order to define the dna
and if we look at this now in 3d you can
see beautiful beautiful segmentations
infinity of all of our cells
this is a beautif a fun little fleety um
way of looking at those and
when we did a validation by a manual
inspection
we found very very high segmentation
accuracy for individual cells and even
entire fields of view
which turns out to scale up actually
quite well in a fully automated way to
our 200
000 200 000 plus cells
so we have those tools in hand and we
have a way to pull the information out
what do we do with it now well the
challenge comes from the fact that cells
themselves need to generate
robust and adaptable behavior
the solution that the cells have for
this is that they generate structures
within
but those structures are stable in a
dynamic sense they are constantly
undergoing
flux of their components so that they
can generate structures that look
relatively stable like these spindles
all while being able to be flexible and
responsive to the needs of the cell in
this case for example the cell cycle
and these green structures here those
are mitochondria just to show you that
the insides of the cells are constantly
in motion
the consequence of that is that if you
took any of these cells this is a field
of cells here
um and took a snapshot they would all
look completely different at any moment
in time
and even flu time they might take
different trajectories
so that means we just have this vast
amount of variation in ourselves
and we have to deal with it so why do we
care about variation the first reason is
because we do have to deal with it
we can't decide what normal is in this
complete sea of variation
if we don't understand where it's coming
from and how you start
uh creating something that is abnormal
so we need this for a baseline
but we want to go one step further and
really take advantage of the variation
and this is one of my favorite quotes by
rick who is the director of our
institute which is that every cell is an
experiment in this
sea of cells because every cell may be
slightly bigger or slightly shorter or
slightly flatter
at any moment in time in what is
completely normal but
in a sense every cell is a slight
perturbation um on what
on what the other cells are doing so if
we could understand what the sources of
variation are we can then control for it
so that we can actually compare cells
and identify patterns and rules that
generate
the organization that we see so
conceptually that sounds all fine but
how do we actually
go about doing that so here are four
movies uh four structures um the cells
going colonies so these are four sort of
colonies
and this is just to show you that
there's a lot of variation in behavior
in the case of the nuclei and the cell
boundaries if we wanted to compare two
cells
we certainly know already most of us as
biologists that we want to take into
account the cell cycle
a cell that is small in a cell that is
large that are just in two different
parts of their you know growth
uh probably shouldn't be directly
compared without taking that into
account because the larger one would
have twice as much of all of its
internal
um components similarly again uh the
behavior of cells and time whether they
um all explore the same you know space
within one particular trajectory of time
and you're just catching them in a
specific moment
or whether they all have a very
particular trajectory that they take
is really important to understanding how
we compare those
so we want to be able to um take all of
these structures
look at how these sources of variation
affect what these structures do and
start to put them together
and that's not so straightforward so
let's start really basic really easy
and see if we can do that conceptually
let's start with just the nuclei
we all look at this picture we all start
to think yes we could analyze the
the shape and movement of behavior of
each of these nuclei so let's do it
well the first thing we need is robust
and accurate segmentation of all these
nuclei
that should be no problem i just showed
you our wonderful segmenter and all of
our tools let's just do that
the problem is that this particular
movie and any movie like it
where the cells can be imaged in 3d for
very long periods of time
hours on end in fluorescence uh
generally works best for lower
resolution and magnification and if we
image ourselves at the resolution we
would want here's a side view
to pick up beautifully the shape of
these nuclei um then we kill the cells
so we have this played off the question
is can we transform our images
and the answer is yes we can um several
several uh
groups out there i was included have
approaches for trying to transform
images from one type to another in our
case um we do
this completely in 3d and with a lot of
validation and we use uh deep learning
conditional again
seagans um to do so and we call those
transfer functions
when we do that and we look at a real
high magnification versus a predicted
high magnification image
we see very low error in um
in the real versus the predicted in this
case for the volume of the nuclei which
is something we do want to measure
so we do it application specific
quantitative validation in any case that
we use this type of a tool
in order to facilitate our work so with
that
we can now in a really beautiful way and
in time lapse
um analyze the 3d uh the 3d shape
of these nuclei
oops apologies for that so now we still
have to track
the nuclei that's a straightforward
thing but not always that easy
um so here we are here our tracks
and what this basically does is it
transforms let's say a field of view of
a high magnification
set of nuclei into
a very very large field of high
magnification instead of nuclei so that
we can actually analyze them
so then we have beautiful
three-dimensional nuclei and we have to
pull numbers out of them to describe
shape
we use spherical harmonics to do this we
generate the coefficients that describe
um uh in increasing accuracy the shape
of the nuclei
and then we perform a principal
component analysis to identify those
primary axes or modes of shape variation
but then we want to understand them so
here we plotted just cells
from the first versus the second
component for these nuclei
and here's a view from the top and two
side views of these nuclei
and as we hold the second principal
component axis fixed
and we move through the first we can see
that the nuclear shape is changing
and if we do that more in time we can
see that more actively
we can do that for all of the other
principal components so this very first
one that you're seeing here
is that basically the size of the
nucleus goes this is the top view
the second principal component would
show that the nuclei are squishing
the third would show from the top view
that they are getting pressed
and then the fourth and fifth relate to
these other sort of versions of getting
squished in the other dimensions
so i'm going to summarize a lot of work
we did using this approach on this one
movie
to tell you what our conclusions were um
and they're
they're actually pretty fun so if we
look closely at how
um through time uh the uh
the mode that was presents the squishing
of the cells um
behaves we can see that uh how squished
a cell is at any moment in time depends
on its neighbors and how
it's doing and how it's moving and that
happens at the time scale of minutes
if we look at size and we follow any one
of these nuclei
you'll see that they grow over time at
the scale of the cell cycle time
and importantly that component that
flatness component how flat the nuclei
are
that relates to um how the cells pack
within the colony and that's a much
longer time scale
so if we want to ask how much variation
is there between
two cells in time it actually depends on
the aspect
of the variation that you're looking at
and each of these sources of variation
map to these three different time scales
so the type of variation
like you care about size do you care
about flatness and the time scale of
variation affects your interpretation of
your data
that's a good approach does that work
for our snapshots does that work for a
huge collection where we have all of our
many many structures
so this is um our image collection which
we're updating currently and hopefully
will be updated online in a few months
of 200 000 cells using these
segmentations with 25 structures
all high resolution 3d images of live
cells
for a collection that we really think is
quite unprecedented and powerful
uh if anybody wants to come and play
with it just like we do
so we do the exact same thing let's just
do the spherical harmonic-based pca
shape space
that's a lot of words um for the cells
and nuclei in our human stem cells
and this lily is a way to measure and
quantify the shape of every one of our
cells in the collection
in a standardized mapping framework and
if you look here
this is a side view for the very first
component this is the top view for the
second component and so on
the first observation you'll see is that
the first five modes are the same as in
the time-lapse analysis
some of the order is switched and in the
case of for example
flatness versus size that's because in
one case we're focusing on time-lapse of
cells through time as they grow
and the other case we're focusing on
many many still images of cells from
many many colonies that are all in a
different sort of
space of packing so that makes a lot of
sense
the other thing that's really fun is
besides flatness and size if you start
looking at these other modes for example
this mode of tiltness that's almost like
an egyptian walk or might one of my
favorites down here which is how
pear-shaped
the cell is if you look from the top you
can see that nuclei can change their
shape dramatically and sometimes they
don't change their shape at all and
instead they're actually changing their
position
so the nuclei tend to follow the shape
modes of the cell
in some sort of way so we can now
decompose
and just briefly talk about each of
these modes just a couple of them
the first is flatness this in the cell
also relates to the packing of the
colonies
which is affected by things like colony
size where you are in the colony
and so on an important one is it could
be affected by the
tagging of the cell lines so we did an
extensive analysis
to look into and make sure that how our
colonies pack is not
simply due to the fact that we have
tagged one particular protein or another
we found that out of our 25 cell lines
there are few
where they pack a little bit differently
from the less of the population
but not by very much and for most of the
cell lines which is actually quite
spectacular
for all of these you know 25 structures
for most of them
they actually behave uh identically
if we look at size that's growth during
the cell cycle what this permits us to
do of course
is think about for our many structures
so at least you know 10 out of these 25
by cytoplasmic structures of interest
how does structure size scale of cell
size in a survey manner
what i mean is how much of the variation
we see in the volume of a structure say
the mitochondria is
explained by just simply the volume of
that cell
what we find is that for many structures
it's quite well behaved and there's
different amounts of variation that are
explained just by cell volume
and for other structures that's not so
much the case what we also find is we
look at structures inside the nucleus
more of the variation is explained when
you consider the nuclear volume than the
cell volume
and so on so um this is actually really
exciting and i don't have time to figure
all of those cells but the idea that we
can think about structure size feeling
in this sort
of you know broad way is really
wonderful in our data set
all of these other modes what they're
really doing is changing
um the way that the cytoplasmic space
looks and also what the nucleus is doing
and so that means that now we can start
asking questions about where all of our
structures are in the cell
given a particular sort of shape of the
cell
so i'm going to show you a preliminary
sneak peek of what that looks like
preliminary because this is not
finalized some of our methods are still
being adjusted
um if we take now look the structures we
can ask what are the locations
in cytoplasms of similar shape we can
create average locations for these
structures in a much more simple way
it's not simple in a much more
straightforward way than if the cells
have many different shapes so we created
a very elegant morphing and
interpolation approach
to start combining cells of similar
shapes
so let's take this particular mode here
and here you can see
22 of the 25 structures and the average
view this is a side view of the cell
of each of these structures the pixillin
which is for
the focal adhesions is at the bottom of
the cell tight junctions is near the top
of the cell
they're beautiful patterns for some of
these organelles
but what we can do now is we can look at
how
these patterns for each of these
structures changes in response to
natural perturbation
for example when the cells are more flat
or larger or in this case sort of more
elongated in one way or the other
we can also start and this is also
preliminary but very exciting to me
looking at the locations of all these
structures relative to each other how
much overlap is there so we can take
the same particular shape space and we
can start painting the structures in and
i can't even overlay all of these into
one because it would look like a big
mess
um and so we can visualize here 13
structures in the same integrated cell
and we can do that through changing the
shape space
and then we can try to think about how
to represent that so this is again very
preliminary because the particular
approaches we're using
to measure the overlap are still being
optimized but if you
uh take each note to be a particular
structure that is represented by some
protein that is tagged in our cell line
and you take the strength of the
connections to be sort of the thickness
and
and darkness of these lines between the
nodes then what you'll notice
is these set of structures here are all
nuclear
and they have strong overlap with each
other as you would expect
they have less but still some overlap
with the nuclear envelope structures
which all overlap a lot with uh the
endoplasmic reticulum that forms a
bridge to the cytoplasm
and then there are structures over here
which represent structures that are
towards the top of the cell or the edge
of the cell that then interact with the
structures at the periphery of the cell
so this is a a mechanism we have to now
create structural interaction maps
in our cells and that's exciting and fun
and and we can see how it reacts to
whether the cells are bigger or smaller
but we want to take that one step
further and say now how does that change
when
cells change right when we go through
this differentiation process
so just briefly in the last two slides
just to tell you where this is heading
if we now look at the early time points
of differentiation when the cells
transform
from epithelia epithelial-like cells
into mesenchymal-like cells as they form
mesoderm
and they go through an emt which is
something that occurs in differentiation
but also in cancer and
inflammation this is what our cells our
colonies look like
so individual cells in the colonies are
labeled what you see is that the
colonies contract very dramatically
and then at about 24 hours they expand
and the cells start moving around and
crawling around with a completely
different morphology and organization
than before
and if we look closely at the nuclei one
of our wonderful prototypes for
analyzing this
we can see all sorts of important
changes in how the nuclei
behave in shape space and so analysis of
these sorts of trajectories
will allow us to get at whether
what types of behaviors occur during
really key state transitions like
developmental differentiation so with
that i want to thank
the whole allen institute for cell
science team
we have extensive contributions from
everyone on the team we all work
together very closely
and i would like to end by thanking our
founder paul allen for his vision
encouragement
and support thank you
are we back
okay yeah thank you sorry guys thank you
suzanne for this very very interesting
talk
so we have several questions from the
audience so let me go um
through them um
first question was how do you define the
edges between colonies that are touching
um yeah so uh oh gosh you guys can't
hear me yet
can you hear me oh good here we go
great let me just add my my video hi um
yeah so um
we can't uh necessarily define edges of
colonies that are touching so
if we want to do colony analysis we
would focus on colonies that are
separate from each other
okay another one well first
complementary this is incredibly cool
for the shape modes are there any
indications that some of the shape modes
change in correlated ways for example
pear-shaped
cells tend to be smaller etc have you
tried any non-orthogonal dimension
reduction techniques to see if some of
them provide the same account of the
data as pca
i love that question we have looked at
whether some shape modes are correlated
some of them are but not in a
in a huge way that affects the result
however we have a
um parallel approach that we're trying
to use to actually compare different
methods of doing um
dimensional adduction we're doing this
right now with pca but we're also doing
this with a beta vae autoencoder
approach a machine learning approach
um because that would be non-linear and
it would allow us to see whether the
cells want to tell us something
different about how
most effectively biological information
should be compressed and then and then
expanded again
so we're actually going to compare both
approaches but the beta vae approach was
not yet ready for
for sharing so
next question um okay another question
um also a compliment great talk and
the question is can the shape mode also
be used to quantify nucleus and time
lapse of right field images in 3d
so um yes with some work so we have a
label-free technology where we can
predict the
fluorescence signal of the outline of a
nucleus or potentially even segment
directly the nucleus from bright field
and we're working on that and others can
work on that too and if you extract the
nuclear shape properly from brightfield
via these label-free approaches you
could absolutely do this and we're we
are
we are trying very hard to get there
okay another question so every question
starts the complement so i will not
repeat them
but um one question is asking what is
the relevance of where the structures
are in a cell
that's a good question yeah so so our
goal here is to say
um if we look at individual image we
know where something is in the cell
but do we know the rules of which
structures localize where
in relation to each other in a
consistent way and in response to
the perturbation for example larger or
flatter cells
and so the the uh elements of this is
sort of that point which is
what are those rules by which structures
localize with each other
are those rules consistent over
perturbation and how do they change when
we go beyond say
shape space for these cells but say
differentiate into another cell type
are the golgi always closely related to
the lysosomes in only our stem cells but
also
in the same way and say a calling cell
right those are the really core
questions of rules of organization we're
trying to get at
okay i think we have to wrap it up in
the interest of time thank you suzanne
for a very interesting and stimulating
talk and thank you everybody for
listening if
anybody has their question not answered
i think that suzanne would have a chance
to later answer your questions in
writing i think
so that's it thank you very much again
and enjoy the rest of the conference
thank you